on this friday night calls to further
cut contacts in canada
i know that it's hard but it is
temporary
what it could mean for christmas plus
the hospitals reaching the breaking
point
also tonight we are in washington d.c
for the countdown to the presidential
election
the frenzied final days of campaigning
and what the astonishing numbers of
early voters could mean
helping heal our neighbors it was the
right place to be at that time
the canadian healthcare workers choosing
to stay
in the u.s and thinking outside the box
canvassing for poppies in unprecedented
times
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are in washington d.c as america
counts down to the presidential election
on november 3rd
canadians don't have a vote but we
certainly have a lot of
interest in what america decides both
candidates are on a final
big push for votes president trump is
holding more than a dozen
rallies between now and monday evening
we will get to that
in just a moment but we begin tonight in
canada because the coronavirus
is spreading in manitoba and other parts
of the country at an alarming rate
and there is new national modeling out
on where things could
be headed the new projections show how
we could
slow the spread if we reduce our
contacts with other people by 25 percent
the curve should bend back down but if
nothing changes in the way we behave
the projection shows the curve climbing
steeply canada could hit 8 000
cases a day by mid-december and if we
increase
our contacts we could hit that mark by
november
in communities where the cases are
rising quickly we need to keep our
contacts as limited as possible
so when you're thinking of seeing people
outside your household ask yourself
is this absolutely necessary
here are the case numbers today quebec
recorded more than 950 positive tests
and 17 deaths there were nearly 900
cases in ontario and nine deaths there
in bc 272 new cases alberta set a new
record
622 manitoba also set a record
480 cases we will take you to winnipeg
which is moving to code red in just a
moment
but first abigail beeman on the big
picture and what it could mean for the
weeks and months
ahead on the day before a different
looking halloween the country's top
doctor is already setting expectations
low for christmas
we do have to celebrate them differently
all the way to christmas
and probably beyond we're working really
hard on vaccines and new treatments
but until then you know big parties are
off
keep your contact groups small stick to
those in your household as much as
possible
that's the message again as officials
released new modeling
we have to continue to engage in these
behaviors
even as it becomes frustrating colvin 19
cases keep
climbing and so do deaths now an average
of 30 canadians are dying
each day while we have consistently
observed the highest
incidence of covet 19 among young adults
aged 20 to 39 years we're now seeing
a concerning rise in the incidents among
individuals 80 years of age and older
which is the age group at highest risk
teresa tam says
more needs to be done to stop outbreaks
in long-term care
but the pattern of outbreaks is shifting
with many more now linked to private
social gatherings than in the spring
weddings funerals community events some
of these events are considered
super spreader events which large
numbers of contacts involved
these put significant strain on public
health capacity
to interrupt transmissions you can see
here hospitalizations are also
on the rise an average of eleven hundred
people are treated each day
but that's far less than the spring peak
of three thousand
dr tam says that's in part due to better
treatment options and the younger age of
patients
but warns like everything else in this
pandemic things
could change abigail beeman global news
ottawa the spike in cases in manitoba
means winnipeg will move to code red on
monday
all other areas will be elevated to
orange in the province's pandemic
response plan and
new restrictions will be in place for a
minimum of two weeks
test positivity rates have hit new highs
8.6 percent
across manitoba and 9.7 percent in
winnipeg
britney greenslade is reporting from
winnipeg tonight
the intensive care unit beds in winnipeg
are filling up
the system is being overwhelmed and
capacity
is a major issue i would argue that that
breaking point was probably
within the last 24 hours and
everybody should be very concerned at
this point in time one winnipeg hospital
doctor who global news has agreed not to
identify for fear of repercussion
has seen the firsthand effects of covet
19 and the struggle is placing on our
health care system
he says they are right on the edge of
making life and death decisions
having to choose between pta and patient
b
because patient a is five years younger
and has one or two less health problems
that's not fair the province says while
there is some capacity
we are at a critical point we are not
there yet
and i think we need to do everything
within our power to do it
so i'm not ready really to have that
conversation
i think we still need to fight fight
this fight
extra capacity is being added
immediately with the province gearing up
overflow space
and redeploying staff where possible i'm
hoping that we can turn this around
now we're obviously getting close i said
on monday that
this was going to be the challenge of
our lifetime
one they say is going to take an effort
from everyone
brittany greenslade global news winnipeg
now to the u.s just four days until a
presidential election and a record high
number of americans have already made
their choice
more than 85 million americans have
voted early in person or
mailed in their ballots in texas more
than 9 million people have voted and
that is more than the state's total
turnout
in 2016. in the final days of the
campaign democratic candidate joe biden
and republican candidate donald trump
are scrambling to motivate and energize
those who have yet to cast
a ballot i have a tremendous victory
it's going to be a victory like none
other it's the most important
election of our lives there's nothing
beyond our capacity
so hawk if you want america to lead
again
our washington bureau chief jackson
frasco is with me jackson this final
push for votes is something else
it really is donna and welcome to
washington this final push is all about
locking this up for either candidate
because right now both of them have
potential paths to winning the
presidency
i want to show you a map that gives you
a sense of this final campaign push here
the states that one or both of the
candidates will be in over the next few
days
those northern rust belt states if they
look familiar it's because those are the
ones
that donald trump won in a squeaker last
time around
now he's pulling even or slightly behind
joe biden so he's really on the defense
there and then when you look at southern
states like florida north carolina and
georgia
trump won them handily last time this
time around
they're in play so trump is really on
the defense in old and new territory
this time around
his strategy to try and lock this up in
the remaining days has him holding
14 rallies between now and election day
for joe biden the strategy is really
about focusing on pennsylvania
because that is one state that biden
camp believes that they could lock up
early and deliver a decisive result on
election night
jackson the early voting numbers are
astonishing what could that record
turnout be a sign of
it's a sign of a few things one is
nervousness about how election day
itself will unfold in the middle of this
raging pandemic and with fears of
potential violence at the polls
and to give you a sense of how
astonishing this is you mentioned those
numbers in texas
more than 100 of 2016 turnout is already
there
other states like north carolina are in
the 80 to 90 percent range this is right
across the board it's really really
remarkable stuff
the other thing to keep in mind here
though is that people may be trying to
read into these early voting results
figure out what they mean we don't know
right now because we don't know who
these people are voting for
what we do know is that it could mean
for a long and potentially very
interesting election
night because they'll pre-count some of
those mail-in results but then results
could shift to a different candidate
as the in-person votes are tallied up
yeah it's going to be a long
night couple of days possibly weeks
jackson prosco thanks
here in the u.s hospitals in many states
are becoming
overwhelmed 21 states are reporting
record daily case numbers of covid19 and
up to 1 000 americans a day are dying
in hospitals near the u.s border among
those treating american patients are
canadian health care workers
our jeff semple is in michigan and he
spoke to some of them
my name is nikki hillis-walters i'm a
nurse
i'm canadian living in the us right now
before the pandemic
hillis walters was living in canada
working two jobs
in windsor and another at a hospital
near detroit
but when kovitt 19 hit she was forced to
pick a side
so she went where the need was greatest
we were getting
slammed with tons of emissions with this
virus that no one had heard
really heard of much before because it
just really felt like it was the right
place to be at that time
steve hammack registered nurse okay
where are you from
windsor ontario homick is one of sixteen
hundred health workers who live in
windsor but commute
cross border to michigan obviously have
friends in the
hospitals in windsor it was quite
different hearing their stories where
there was only a few people in their
icus at one point
as opposed to ours where we had to
literally create a new icu
house all these patients because it was
so out of control
like two different worlds really and
another difference many of their
american patients
can't afford to get sick they were
trying to beat it on their own or trying
to just to
avoid the cost that it would be doing to
treat it right
so by the time they were coming in it
was like almost too late right
because it's like now they're too far
gone hi i'm wendy
brothers-peterson i am
a canadian i am a um
rn case manager for hospice for a large
rural area of montana brothers peterson
says in her care facilities she's often
the only one
wearing a mask the majority of the
families
um give me a look there are um
comments about masks with
the rhetoric that unfortunately
the president of this country has made
normal
it's hard not to be angry but there have
also been moments
of hope at the height of the first wave
hillis walters looked out the window
to see this people in this community
like did a parade around the hospital
they honked and they drove through and
they had signs and local
restaurants were sending food it's an
opportunity to come together
and i think that that starts with
you know not seeing myself as like a
canadian necessarily an american or just
like a nurse helping a human
a number of those cross-border canadian
health care workers told us that at the
beginning of the pandemic
they were offered the opportunity to
remain in canada to ride out the
pandemic
north of the border but all of them said
the same thing
not a chance donna
so much work to do jeff semple thank you
well back in 2016 donald trump lost
minnesota by about 45
000 votes this time he's hoping his
tough record on immigration
might make the difference heather
urich's west is in minnesota tonight
st cloud minnesota is a quiet community
about an hour's drive from the twin
cities
less than 70 thousand people call it
home
but within the last decade a growing
number of residents have moved here
from other countries a search of
refugees
specifically from somalia families of
new immigrants
mostly refugees were attracted by jobs
at nearby meat processing plants
but adjusting to the sudden influx of
new faces
more than fifteen hundred people in just
a few years
was difficult for some who felt the
community was changing
too fast much of donald trump's
campaigning in minnesota has focused on
this issue
at rallies in the state he's called
somali refugees criminals
and terrorists and what does biden now
propose while the pandemic still
smolders around the globe
increasing refugees by 700 percent from
the most
unstable vulnerable dangerous parts of
the world
21-year-old ikram emolgi came to saint
cloud as a refugee six
years ago she now teaches high school
and says members of her community are
tired of feeling attacked
we have a president of this country that
are coming in our communities and
specifically targeting us the problem
perhaps with that strategy
is refugees are not illegal immigrants
many have gone on to become u.s citizens
and in this election they can vote our
community are so
so excited to vote out trump and
minnesota's somali community
isn't alone greg king works with many in
the state who have come
from southeast asia we're talking about
you know
five to seven percent of the electorate
here in minnesota
so it's definitely more than enough to
swing an election
immigrants who've grown tired of being
targeted eager to use their vote
to fight back heather eurix west global
news
st cloud minnesota
a new twist on a popular fundraiser
coming up how this year's poppy campaign
is getting a reboot
the poppy campaign is one of the
best-known fundraising campaigns in
canada
it happens every year in the lead-up to
remembrance day but as mike licout
reports like everything else in 2020
the royal canadian legion has had to
adapt
did you want a puppy here do you want to
wash your hands it's the traditional
poppy campaign with pandemic provisions
i love this plexiglas protects doreen
rock and beverly ann kelford
who for the first time in decades can't
physically pin poppies on people
i'm a person i like to give a hug i like
to pin on the puppies
but we have to follow the rules and
that's the way it is those health
considerations mean many locations
across the country will have just a
poppy box with no volunteer
or veteran the royal canadian legion
hopes that won't mean
fewer donations canadians are extremely
generous
and i really think that they are going
to understand that
we are in unprecedented times here the
goal is to match the approximately 20
million dollars raised last year
all of that money goes towards veteran
services and
they hope this will help
the pay tribute tap box automatically
deducts a two dollar donation when you
use a tap enabled device or card
it was already being developed with hsbc
long before the pandemic hit
but it now feels fortuitous most of us
don't
have cash in our pockets anymore and
you know there's now the the covet
situation where folks don't want to
touch things the pilot project will be
in limited locations across the country
something else that's limited these
legion masks
originally given to veterans in
long-term care facilities they're also
being sold on the legion's website
with proceeds going to help local legion
branches
thank you for doing this beverly ann and
doreen are getting used to working with
the gloves masks and hand sanitizer
kovid 19 or not they're determined to be
here
so that no one forgets those who paid
the ultimate sacrifice for our country
mike lacouter global news ottawa
what's at stake for canadians in the u.s
election ahead i put that question to
canada's ambassador to the u.s
tonight global national is broadcasting
from washington d.c
we're back in a moment
welcome back canada's ambassador to the
united states is kirsten hillman
she got the job in march but before that
she was deputy ambassador
and played a key role in trade
negotiations so she knows the us well
she's a diplomat and so isn't picking
sides in this election
but she does acknowledge there is a
great deal at stake i spoke to her
earlier and started
by asking how the last four years have
tested the relationship between canada
and the us you know the the last four
years
have as canadians know seen us
renegotiate the nafta with the u.s
administration
and that was a process that wasn't
always easy it had its ups and downs and
its challenging moments
but the the benefit of those discussions
was that it allowed us to really
build a lot of strong relationships with
with this administration the trump
administration
and many of our colleagues in the senate
and in in the house on the hill
and i think that you know it's those
relationships that have helped us a lot
in recent months as we've been trying to
manage
some of the challenges of covid together
so like
any really deep and profound
relationship there are tests from time
to time
but when you have strong relationships
right from the
leaders on down to the officials that
are dealing with each other every single
day
then you know we can get through a lot
of things together and the past few
months have shown that
they're very effective relationships
that we have in place well yeah and
right now there is a lot to get through
the border is closed there's no end in
sight to the pandemic
canada and the us are both in recession
where where do you see
a bright spot if you see one in that
picture
well you know the bright spot i see is
that the cooperation
that we've been able to have with the us
government and u.s
stakeholders and governors over the
course of the pandemic
i think you mentioned the border
restrictions on non-essential travel i
think that's a really good example
because we were able to come to a
decision um back in march
on restricting non-essential travel
between canada and the us
and just put that in context our border
has on average in a normal times 400
000 crossings every single day it's the
busiest land border in the world
and if you think about the magnitude of
the decision the fact we could do it so
quickly is a real testament
to our cooperation collaboration and our
understanding that we really are
partners that need each other in
in many many ways you know canadians are
watching this election very closely
there's concern about how partisan and
divided the us
is right now what would you say to
canadians and what will you be watching
for on tuesday night
we are all watching the u.s election
canadians are watching it americans are
watching it
the world is watching it um and and
that's a testament
to the role that they play in our world
so we will we will watch
and we will we will have confidence in
the americans to
choose their leadership and move on and
continue to play a very very important
role in our in our society in our world
ambassador hillman thank you so much for
taking the time
thank you so much and you can see the
full interview with the ambassador on
our website
news dot ca slash global national we are
in washington dc as america enters the
final stretch of the presidential
campaign
we're back in a moment
you're watching global national
welcome back to washington there is a
lot going on this year and it can feel
tumultuous and stressful
we all need a way to take a break from
it all to sort of soothe our souls
and so we've asked a man named stuart
reynolds to help us out
you've probably heard of him he goes by
the name brittlestar and his takes
on what's happening in the news have
gone viral on both sides of the border
tonight he has a message for our
neighbors
hi america canada here and if you're
american and watching this it means
you're one of the over 600 000
americans who live in canada or you're
watching online
from america pretending you live in
canada
we know you've got this election coming
up and i know it seems like a big deal
and that's probably because it is but
don't worry
we'll be here for you no matter what
happens it's like when a good friend is
in a relationship
it's not really our place to criticize
the other person
but after a few drinks we probably will
but know this america no matter what
happens this election
if you decide to stay in the
relationship or you decide to end it and
start seeing someone saying
i mean new we'll be here for you like a
good friend
with a tub of ice cream and a couple of
spoons
maybe some maple syrup and probably beer
don't bring beer we're gonna need
canadian beer
only the good stuff and that is global
national for this friday from washington
i'm donna friesen tomorrow we're
bringing back our program called the new
reality which premiered in the spring
i'll have a profile of daniel dale the
canadian reporter whose full-time job is
fact-checking president trump and
boy has he been busy that and much more
tomorrow on the new reality right here
on global
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye
you